great apartment.
So many cool pieces.
Great, like,
cabinets and--
Right, enough.
Beard, where
your room at?
Right back there
on the right.
Oh, God, finally.
Later.
Oops.
That's too many.
You wanna?
Yeah, sure, okay.
Yeah? Okay.
That's dope.
That's my art.
Oh, cool.
What is this?
That's a little
embarrassing.
That's my
grandfather's sweater.
He's dead and this is the
last thing of his I have.
Sometimes I sleep
in it, you know,
it just reminds
you of him.
Would you put it on?
Sure.
Were you, like,
close with him?
He was, like, my best
friend, you know?
We did tons of
stuff together.
He taught me how to fish,
skip stones, whittle.
Did you, like, cry,
when he died?
Can I be honest
with you?
Please.
I cried so hard
I thought I didn't
have any more tears
left in me.
Oh, my God.
He was like my best
friend, you know?
And my worst enemy.
Totally.
Wait, wait,
wait, wait.
I want to take
this slow.
It's gonna take a long
time to get my dress off,
so that's gonna--
It's kind of
super slow.
You know what?
We should go up to the
roof, the view is sick.
Okay.
It sounds super
sexy and romantic.
So romantic.
Oh, my God,
what the--
Holy shit!
What?